alors pierre je me suis inspiré à du
père sont que je rencontrais de ma vie à
leur manière de parler à leur façon
d'agir mais mais j'imagine eshiro comme
à gauche moderne et cette intuition m'a
permis d'interpréter des personnages
c'est vrai
elle
comme tout les personnages de la série
n'existe pas c'est un personnage fictif
sa vie à l'ensemble du de biographies
qui raconte d'une personnalité qui ont
traversé notre pays
bien sûr mais dit la série m'a donné
beaucoup d'opportunités pour le cinéma
en italie mais j'espère de travailler au
cinéma en france
à leur flore pour moi dans la série okal
du personnage mais les respectables
par contre je travaille avec deux
comédiens merveilleux qui mérite un
énorme respecter
cédric je ne peux pas parler mais alors
g/j beaucoup d'acteurs que je m'inspire
de mon travail on particulière dit le
manager en comédienne italienne
parce que je laime et oui bien sûr
j'aimerais travailler avec paulo que
l'un des plus grands réalisateurs du
monde
bonjour
et alors là c'est la plus difficile à
tourner est celle où nous raconte la
morte dumas nous un jour victime de la
camorra assassiné pas des criminels et
les souvenirs de cette histoire m'a
donné la prison plus la durée de leurs
tournages et de personnages mal an dans
la réalité s'appelle d'une semelle à
verdun